today we happen to need to learn what
babies tell us and we're in fantastic
hands because professor Paul bloom much
soft much-sought-after speaker is let me
tell us about these so why did you help
me welcome to the podium good um my name
is is Paul bloom I'm a professor in the
Yale psychology department this may be a
bit of an unusual science Saturday I'm
not here to talk about physics or
chemistry or biology I'm here to talk
about the science of the human mind and
I'm actually want to talk about a
specific problem that's long interested
me and that has to do with human
kindness question is where does human
kindness human niceness come from and
I'll start with a story that the
anthropologist Sarah heard he tells her
great book mothers and others so hurry
describes being on an airplane and she's
not flying business class she's not
flying first class she's flying coach
she's crammed in with a lot of people
she's sitting squeezed in with people
you know I'm foods she's already been
through security so somebody touched her
and they saw her naked and everything
and and foods being pushed through the
card since she's not getting it and then
somewhere she hears a baby crying and
she sees other people and our kind of
rolling their eyes and to make the time
go by a bit better because she also
studies chimpanzees she asked a question
she says I cannot keep from wondering
what would happen if my fellow human
passengers suddenly morphed into another
species of ape what if I were traveling
for planeload of chimpanzees any one of
us would be lucky to disembark with all
ten fingers and toes still attached with
the babies still breathing and unnamed
bloody earlobes and other appendages
with litter two aisles compressing so
many highly impulsive strangers into a
tight space would be a recipe for mayhem
how many people here have ever flown on
a long flight how many people here on
the flight when a plane landed there
were body parts on the floor human you
know I've no doubt this happened once or
twice but billions of people fly each
year and summon how we manage to keep
from killing each other and that's kind
of a puzzle as a psychologist what makes
this different in general people are
nice and this shows up in all sorts of
ways so um we give to charity Americans
give billions of dollars each year to
charity now some people who are cynical
point out that some of the charities we
might give to help ourselves we might
give money to a museum that we like to
go to or we might give money to a
university of women don't want we want
our children to go to but some of the
charity we give to people in faraway
lands some of us here gave to the people
who suffer from the disasters in Haiti
or in Japan these are people who we
might not know who can do nothing for us
who will never know that it was us who
helped it's still we are motivated to
help we leave tips we leave tips and
restaurants now if you went to the
restaurant over and over again you might
leave a tip because you want better
service next time but we leave tips and
restaurants were never going to go back
to we give money to strangers and if
that in general we help strangers my
favorite experiment on this was done by
stanley milgram at yale university so
Stanley Milgram was very famous for an
experiment on human cruelty where he got
people to believe that they shocked one
another and he found it even under some
circumstances people do terrible things
to each other but he was also interested
in niceness he did a very very clever
study he had envelopes with stamps on
them in an address and this was an
address of a house he had and what he
did was very simple he took these steel
envelopes with stamps and he walked
through the streets of New Haven and he
put some places he put it on a Ledge he
dropped it under a lamp post he stuck it
in a branch of a tree and the question
was very simple
how many of these would be sent and the
answer was amazing about eighty percent
of them were sent people picked up an
envelope looked at it saw it had a stamp
on it and they put it in a mailbox and
sent it out now maybe you could argue
that it's just baby government employees
or something doing it automatically but
it needed something clever he found that
it would only send us out if they
believed if they didn't think the letter
was going to a bad person so what he did
was he did to study again but this time
instead of somebody's name on the
envelope Joe Smith he wrote friends of
the Nazi Party in that case men of the
envelopes went back to it people must
have ripped it up or through in a
governor we said oh my gosh friends of
Nazi Party I'll put in them post
somebody recently replicated us in New
York City and this time they didn't put
stamps on the envelopes they just had on
blows without stamps still about a
quarter of them came back I can't even
stamp my own envelopes yet there are
people who fight oh my goodness I'll go
home I'll put a stamp on it and send it
back that's kind of a puzzle and so as a
psychologist I'm interested in where our
niceness comes from now there are a lot
of ways you could ask this question you
could ask it as an evolutionary question
our species has evolved through history
what happened in our evolution to make
us nice you could ask this from the
standpoint of a society or a culture
what happened to Americans or Africans
or Asians or whatever it I made their
society nights but I'm a developmental
psychologist and I want to answer it
from the perspective of children I want
to look at the question of where does
niceness come within every one of us to
put it a bit differently we were all
babies once how many of us heading
everybody in this room has some of the
niceness I'm talking about where did it
come from in our development will reborn
this way now many people believe the
answer is no many people scientists and
philosophers and religious people
believe we have no natural niceness um
this is nicely expressed in a headline
in a magazine onion anybody here read
the onion the onion is not a
magazine is a satire so um so but the
headline here is new study reveals most
children unrepentant sociopaths which
means that most children are sort of you
know like psychopathic killers and
everything now it was a joke headline
but it captures what many people think
which is those of you who are children
are those of you have children may be
familiar with the idea that children are
monsters no offense to anybody uh but as
they say callous monsters who would
remorse Lee exploit them to exploit to
obtain something as insignificant as an
ice cream cone or new toy but I don't
think that that's right I think there's
a better view of human nature and this
was actually expressed by Thomas
Jefferson so Jefferson wrote many years
ago the moral sense our conscience is as
much a part of man as this leg or arm it
has given to all human beings in a
stronger or weaker degree as for civ
members has given them in a greater or
lesser degree the language is a bit
archaic but what he means here is we
have a moral sense a sense of right and
wrong the same way we have arms and legs
now it's true that some people might
have muscular strong arms and legs and
others might have weak arms and legs
just like some of us might have a highly
developed moral sense and others a week
or moral sense but we all have it and as
an example of this so Jefferson wrote
this in America of course but thousands
of miles away at the same time Adam
Smith the great philosopher Adam Smith
thought about this he wrote he gave an
example of what we all have he says when
we see a stroke aimed and just ready to
fall upon the leg or arm of another
person we naturally shrink and draw back
her own leg or arm and when it does fall
we feel it in some measure and are hurt
by it as well as the sufferer and what
he means is that when we see somebody
else in pain it hurts us here's a
picture which I think nicely illustrates
this
now now he is not in any real pain
himself but he's tensing up and
anticipated he feels it um if you ever
watch a movie where somebody is being
beaten or somebody falls down or
somebody is being kicked in the wrong
place you make a whole tensing up an
empathetic response and this might be
the foundation of morality some
hardwired caring for others so we know
it's true for children one way to make a
baby cry is to expose it to other crying
babies now psychologists are a very very
cynical bunch and so when his finding
first came out they said that doesn't
mean anything babies are really stupid
and they're so stupid that when they
hear crying they think I must be crying
and they get upset and they cry some
more so then very clever psychologists
did another experiment where they played
babies tape recorded sounds of their own
crime versus tape recorded sounds of
other babies crying and founded a crime
or four other babies and for themselves
suggest met it really has to do with
other people we know that some sort of
kindness as expressed in sharing and
helping is universal humans everywhere
will often share even share food with
those close to them like their brothers
and sisters like they're close friends
recently people have studied this in the
laboratory so in a very nice study by
Felix marne again and Michael Tomasello
they put toddlers in a situation where
an adult was in some sort of trouble and
they wanted to see a toddler would help
the adult even if nobody was prompting
him and I'll show you a short video from
one of their studies that illustrates
this
now at Yale University I've been
involved with experiments with young
babies looking now not really at how
they behave when they see another person
in pain and not really looking at
whether they help others but looking at
their understanding of right and wrong
and this is work I've done in
collaboration of my colleague and my
wife Karen Wynn who runs the Yale infant
laboratory here and we study we study
babies in her laboratory and the first
studies we did we're looking at how
babies makes predict the actions of
other individuals this was done without
with Valerie kuhlmeier and I'll show you
what baby saw so I'm per second I'm on
in a segment ask you to imagine that
you're a baby watching something but
what baby but what we did was we had a
case where somebody is being helped by
one character and hindered roughed up by
another character and the question we
were interested in is what would babies
expect that guy to do would they expect
him to go to the one that helped them or
the one that hindered him now for adults
that's a no-brainer you go to the one it
helps you're not the one that hurt you
but we wanted to see if kids had the
same belief and the way we tested this
because you can't ask a nine month old
or 12 month oh they can't talk but you
could tell what they expect or what
surprises them by where they look and
how long they look at something so i'll
show you imagine yourself as a baby and
this is what you see in one of our
studies
and then the quake then we would show
you different videos we show you video
like this and a video like this and if
you were a baby where you would probably
do is you would do what you find in our
experiment for both nine month olds and
twelve month olds they would look longer
when the character approached the one
that hindered it then the one that
helped it and for a baby babies look
longer at scenes that surprise them that
don't make any sense to them so that was
our first set of studies but then we
decided and this was in collaboration
with this brilliant graduate student we
got Kylie Hamlin to ask a simpler
question so forget about what babies
predict about other characters what do
babies themselves think of these guys so
what we did was we gave up on fancy
movies what if they're real blocks real
shapes and what if they saw this and
they could touch them what would they do
so again imagine yourself a baby
actually you'll see now a picture the
cameras going to show both what the baby
sees and another level the baby him or
herself
so then we wanted to see which one to
baby like more the good guy or the bad
guy now again you can't ask a baby but
there to determine which one the baby
likes more you get the baby to choose
and before I tell you the results of
this experiment I want to tell you a
little bit about the methods we use to
test babies because some of you might
wonder here how do we know the baby is
choosing the one that's the good guy or
bad guy maybe the baby chooses likes a
certain color or a certain shape and a
way we figured out experimentally is we
do something the word is
counterbalancing but what this basically
means is we make sure that half the time
to good guy is blue and half the time
too bad guy is blue we make sure half
the time to good guys a square and half
the time too bad guys I swear and that
way we know that if babies have a
difference they can't be doing it on the
basis of color and shape some of you may
be wondering with something else how do
we know the mother who's holding the
baby isn't cueing the baby somehow or
the person who's holding up the choice
isn't cueing the baby somehow and the
way we get our eat not even like not
because they're trying to fake the
experiment or sheet but because
unconsciously you know they might do it
and the way we do it is and here's
another experimental word blind they
don't know themselves what the right
answer is so the person offering the
baby to choice didn't get to see what
the baby saw so she doesn't even know
what to write answers she couldn't q
even if she wanted to this is an example
of a baby making a choice just so you
see what looks like
you
and these are our results for both 10
month olds and six month old they would
tend overwhelmingly to reach for the
good guy than the bad guy um this was
published in a journal Nature a couple
of years ago and I think for any of
these papers I'm going pretty quickly
through them giving you a general sense
but but you could always email me on my
email is Paul bloom at yale edu i will
answer any questions about this now also
send you any of the papers for the
details we also want to a three month
olds now three month holes are as some
of you know their meat loaf's their
lumps they can't even reach what they
could do one thing they can look and we
knew from other studies that babies tend
to look at the one they like so we redid
the study this time we didn't ask them
to reach we just held up these guys and
we saw which one they looked at longer
and we found they looked at the good guy
what we call a pro-social guy longer
than the antisocial day now the
experiments I've told you so far
involved this helping up a hill and
pushing down a hill and some of you
might be thinking because we worried
about this too maybe there's something
strange about that maybe you don't want
to you don't want to do all your
research using one design so we we began
a few years ago to do different good guy
bad guy scenarios and I'm not going to
go through these in detail but I'll give
you one example of a study we did I
won't tell you even the results because
it worked out i won't give you details
but i want you to look at these videos
and i want you to guess yourself imagine
yourself being a baby who do you think
the good guy is and who do you think the
bad guy is i'll show you two videos one
after another
I think your intuition is probably the
same as mine and we found in our studies
the babies had the same intuition I
won't show you data but i'll show you
what i find is a very cute film of a
baby making a choice
now some of you some of you may wonder
well this is all sort of choosing a good
guy versus a bad guy and we're doing
this because we're interested in the
origin of kindness origin of morality
but there's more to morality than
choices and we are trying to explore the
question of to what extent is what
babies are doing similar to what adults
are doing when you judge somebody is
good and bad and we began to be
interested in one thing which is for an
adult if I think what you're doing is a
good thing in a moral sense what I'd
like to do is reward you to give you
something that doesn't you don't just
give people something for no reason but
but that's what you do for good things
another night if I think that something
is you're doing is an immoral thing a
bad thing not just something I don't
like but immoral I'm more likely to
punish you reward and punishment connect
up with morality at least for adults so
he won the seat this is true for babies
so here we tested older babies these are
19 month olds because it's more
complicated and what we did was we
showed them the same good guy bad guy
characters I just told you about and the
question was they were not he just
didn't give a choice they had to choose
whether to reward a character in one
study to give a treat or to punish a
character to take away a treat and here
are the results when the character when
a question was who do you reward they
tended to reward a pro-social guy that's
a fancy word meaning a good guy but when
a question was who do you punish they
tend to punish the antisocial guy the
bad guy I'll show you a little clip
which is my favorite baby clip that I've
ever seen and I will warn you I'll be
honest most babies didn't do this but
this wasn't a punishment experiment so
what just happened was a baby took away
one from the bad guy and he did
something else he whacked them
I think these experiments suggest that
there's a sense of natural niceness to
us well we find in babies is some sort
of care for others some ability to do a
mortal evaluation to judge right and
wrong in some sense of justice I think
that when it comes to adults at least
this niceness isn't just a sort of
burden we suffer through but a source of
pleasure so I'm going to do something
absolutely terrible right now and I'm
going to mention I have a book that I
just published you can get it at amazon
for a significant discount um call how
pleasure works which is about the
pleasure of everyday life and one
argument I make in the book is that
kindness morality is a great source of
pleasure I'll tell you this and I'll
give you two arguments for this one
argument is if you ask people how their
lives are doing how happy they are how
rich your lives are and then you ask
them how much do you give to charity and
how much do you volunteer the answers
are very tightly related that the
technical term for that is they're
correlated and that means they go
together find me somebody who's very
happy i bet that person gives a lot to
charity and volunteers find me somebody
who's very sad i bet the person doesn't
now there are exceptions and one can be
very critical about which way it goes
maybe volunteering makes you happy or
maybe being happy makes you more likely
to volunteer but there definitely is a
connection a second bit of evidence is
from laboratory studies so it turns out
that studies of what makes people happy
sometimes indicated by brain scans find
that one of the best things you could do
with ten dollars from a selfish point of
view if you only care about your own
happiness is to give it away the act of
giving away something to somebody who
you perceive as needy is a great boost
in happiness we are naturally nice and
that sort of the first main part of my
talk but now I want to turn a little bit
and make and kind of get a little bit
more cynical we're naturally nice to
those around us
but how do we instinctively respond to
strangers how do we think we respond to
people who aren't part of our group an
answer I think is with fear hatred and
disgust so um we see this in babies when
babies are about nine months of age and
they encounter a stranger they feel a
lot of anxiety psychologists who are
very very clever have used a wonderful
term to describe this called stranger
anxiety and and now you could say well
that's babies but it turns out that most
humans in small-scale societies sometime
in a big society compose a millions of
people like we live in here but a
smaller community like where most humans
used to used to live in the situations
where we've evolved you find a similar
response to strangers I'll give you two
two quotes that support this one is by
the anthropologist Jared Diamond and
he's talking about small groups in Papua
New Guinea and he writes to venture out
of one's territory to meet other humans
even if they lived only a few miles away
was equivalent to suicide Margaret Mead
is one of the world's most famous
anthropologists and she was famously a
defender of what was then called
primitive societies she would um she
would argue that we that we should
actually live our own lives more like
those in primitive societies but she was
also very honest about how these people
dealt with strangers and she wrote most
primitive tribes feel that if you run
across one of those subhumans from a
rival group in a forest the most
appropriate thing to do is bludgeon him
to death I'll finally say something
brief about discussed so discussed is a
human Universal it is um it has a facial
a basic characteristic sorry a basic
facial expression when you're disgusted
you boo and we are mostly disgusted
everywhere by animals and
by-products what i mean by i want to
give you a list of things and I bet
people find everything on the list gross
imagine it dumped on your on your lab
feces urine blood vomit rotten flesh and
most meat are disgusting meat is
interesting people are perfectly
comfortable eating the meat in which
they are raised how many people be
comfortable eating a hamburger are
people willing to eat hamburger okay
what about dog rat yeah you put down
your hand over their rat good rat human
very oh and so you want to go boy am I
telling you this what does this have to
do we're from with morality well it
turns out that many of us instinctively
can find strange people discussing
anybody know who he is Darwin excellent
Charles Darwin the discoverer of
evolution was a wonderful observer of
human nature and he wrote he will
describe very honestly feelings of
disgust towards other people so here's a
famous quote in Tierra del Fuego a
native touch with his finger some cold
preserved meat and plainly show
discussed at its softness whilst I felt
utter disgust in my food being touched
by a naked savage though his hands did
not appear dirty and in my own research
I'm asking for a meaning of time I'm
going to skip past a little bit but I'm
in my own research I found that disgust
can differences in how you experience
discussed can affect how you react to
other people so i'll tell you about two
studies one study is you can get people
to people differ in how easily disgusted
they are how many people would be really
and so there are scales that measure how
easily disgusted you are i'll give you a
scale how many people i mean here's an
example you have to pick up a dead cat
with your hands how many people that
would be really grossed out by that
how many people not so grossed out
that's a difference here's another one
and this one seems here's one two might
seem really minor you go on to a city
bus and you sit down and a seat still
warm from the last person on it how many
of you be really disgusted by that yes
how many people think what I'm not
discussed at all that's another
difference it turns out now this is this
is not a huge relationship and those of
you who are easily discussed it
shouldn't get worried about this but it
turns out how easily disgusted you are
is related to your negative attitudes
about other people like a gay men and
gay women and immigrants people from
other lands people who are more easily
discussed to show a tendency to be more
hostile to others we also find this in
the laboratory so there's a lot of
experiments by the University of
Virginia psychologist Jonathan height
and then some work I've done with my
colleagues I'll tell you about the
studies too weird to study I've ever
done you're going to okay you bring
people into the lab in there's two
groups of people so one group of people
you bring them into lab and they sit
down at a table and you tell them we
want to get your moral judgments about
right and wrong about all sorts of
people what do you think of this kind of
person what do you think of that kind of
person and then you get your data and
that's it the second group you tell them
to go in the room and answer the same
questions but before they go in a room
we spray the room with a fart spray this
is the only study I've ever done it has
a fart spray in it so you spray the room
with a fart spray so people go in and go
oh this isn't like this isn't a good
room and and okay and then you ask them
for your moral judgments now what
difference should try to make from a
logical point of view how smelly the
room is but it does make a difference
being grossed out makes you mean and it
makes you more morally disapproving of
other groups we are not naturally nice
to strangers I think our kindness is
triggered by people around us by our
family by our friends but I think when
dealing with somebody we know it to be a
stranger it changes us a bit
but that sets of a puzzle and this
puzzle has been pointed out by a lot of
very wise philosophers and psychologists
like robert wright and peter singer and
steven pinker that we've gotten better
so we started off as a species with a
very narrow niceness but we've gotten
better this is I'm sorry this scale
didn't show up here but this is a scale
of the death rate from warfare the
number of people who died at the hands
of another scale over time where this is
the 20th century and then you go back
through time and here's the thing to
note about this yes good question each
of these bars is the proportion of
humanity so and so one way of looking at
this is you could say in the many people
say that the last century was the
bloodiest century it was a horribly
bloody violent terrible century and when
you add up all the numbers of people who
died in World War 1 in World War two you
find a lot of humanity would died at the
hands of another of others it was
absolutely horrific the 20th century the
only thing worse than 20th century was a
19th century which was really bad only
thing worse than a 19th century was the
18th century and it turns out that that
if you were born now as a human now your
odds of getting killed by another person
are far less than if you were born a
thousand years ago and far far less than
if you were a hunter gatherers in a
small society and this is an objective
sense in which humans have gotten better
then there's other ways we have made I
think moral progress most humans in this
room think that slavery sexism and
racism are bad things they're morally
wrong but but when you get to a certain
point of our of our ancestors they
wouldn't say they were morally wrong
they had the same brains as us but they
had different beliefs also we
a kind to those who are neither family
nor friends there's the institution of
long distance charity of caring for
people say who suffered in the disaster
in Japan exists now and didn't use to
exist so these are puzzles and the
question is what happened what made us
nicer talking about babies is half the
story but the other half of the story
has to be about what isn't in our heads
what has changed and I think there's a
lot of answers to that question but I
want to close this lecture by giving you
one sort of case study of something
which i do think has changed our moral
views and I think it's very interesting
as a psychologist and this is the
imagination and in particular stories so
it's long been known that stories can
change your moral perspective and people
often try to use stories to shape the
morality of other people in particular
parents often use stories to change the
morality of their children so for
instance if you are a liberal parent and
you want to get your children to believe
in liberal views about the sort of
different families that can exist in a
broad range of non-traditional families
you might give your children a book like
heather has two mommies about a family
that's different from the normal one
because you want your child think that
this is right if you are a conservative
parent you may want to give your
children a bit of a different book like
help mum there are liberals under my bed
and in general there's a belief that
these moralizing stories can shape how
we think about the world I'll tell you I
am very skeptical I think actually kids
are extremely smart and there's a lot of
evidence that kids can detect a mile
away an attempt to persuade them to
something to tell if this is goodness as
bad and they're smart enough to sort of
filter to this out often I think stories
get their effect in a very different way
they get their effect as information
sources and I'll make it clear what I
mean by this but here's a sort of
example um I an Hirsi Ali wrote a book
where she described have
he broke with a very strong form of
religious fundamentalism and she talked
about what made her move away from
religious fundamentalism and part of the
answer was stories what she described as
tales of freedom adventure of equality
between girls and boys trust and
friendship these stories were not great
literature they were not attempts to
persuade in fact a particular book she
was talking about were the Nancy Drew
series these weren't written as great
moral fables but they present a world
that takes certain things is true like
the equality between boys and girls
freedom equality adventure and that
could change how you see the world
stories in particular can work because
they can exploit natural empathetic
responses what that means is they can
make you feel they can turn anonymous
strangers into people who matter Joseph
Stalin one of the most terrible people
on earth summarized this very nicely
when he said a single death is a tragedy
a million deaths is a statistic and
Mother Teresa famously known for
charitable efforts had a similar idea
when she wrote if i look at the mass i
will never act if i look at the one I
will stories can make things personal
you could you could be moved by seeing
an individual but a story can make you
look at the world and see people in
terms of individuals and can change your
moral view and is this studied by
psychologists so this is part of us of a
study by Paul slovic and his colleagues
and what they did was they did us for a
real charity and what he did was they
gave people descriptions statistical
descriptions of suffering like this and
then they saw how much they would give
and that's to answer it would give to
average person will give a little hey a
little bit more than a dollar but for
the other group of people they did
something different they showed a
picture and a name and a person and that
had a huge effect now
all of this may be news to psychologists
it's not news to the people who who
construct charities they don't throw
numbers at you they throw people at you
I'll give you an anecdote of mine for
when I was a graduate student I was
arguing of a friend of mine saying we
should give a lot more to charity and we
give Americans are too selfish and
finally he got really fed up at me with
me and said how much do you give to
charity and I have taste yeah dude i'm
making a theoretical argument here but
but I thought about it and I didn't give
very much so I contacted um what's now
planned USA and asked him for
information about their charity and a
little while later this was before the
internet got so popular I got a package
from them and I remember open remember
opening up the package and expecting to
see pamphlets full of numbers and data
but they did something extraordinarily
clever they sent me a child they said
thank you for writing we know you're not
committed but if you choose to commit
here is a child whose life you will save
and they had a photograph and a letter
he wrote and a drawing of his house
where he lived in his village and it was
immensely persuasive we can we we are
wired up to be to be incited to kindness
by seeing people not numbers not
statistics um and this could have an
effect on our morality more generally
the philosopher Martha Nussbaum talks
about this in the context of Greek
tragedies so she says that although all
of the future citizens who saw age and
tragedies were male they were asked to
have to suffer to have empathy the
suffering of many whose law could never
be there's such as Trojans and Persians
and Africans such as wives and daughters
and mothers um what stories can do is
they could take the world from being an
undifferentiated mass movie to think
about them as specific individuals and
have you think about them as friends and
family I've talked about laboratory
studies that this happens but it most
likely happens in the real world as well
does anybody know who this is for me
harriet beecher stowe and harriet
beecher stowe uh was a novelist and this
was in America and it was right before
it was a during the time of slavery and
slavery according to slavery according
to many historians and many scholars was
not ended by by theological arguments by
religious arguments or legal arguments
or philosophical discussions or moral
arguments it was largely ended through
the force of the imagination and in
particular she was the author of Uncle
Tom's Cabin now there's probably many
reasons why slavery came to an end but
Uncle Tom's Cabin is argued to play a
huge role because what it did was it
when you read it it put you in it put
your reader who could be a wealthy white
man in the perspective of somebody who
was suffering under slavery and this
empathetic force can change the world
there's the story of Abraham Lincoln
meeting Harriet Beecher Stowe for the
first time perhaps a not a real story
but is it but it's a nice story
nonetheless of him meeting her in his
first words worse this was this was as a
civil war was in full steam say so your
little lady who wrote that book that
started this great war and that's an
example of how empathy can change the
world I'm interested in where does our
niceness come from I think part of the
answer is it comes from the minds of
babies support answers at work we're
born with it but I think the rest an
answer comes from other capacities that
have to be nurtured like our
intelligence our culture and our
imagination thank
you